welcome to beyond Corp in a bottle when
we explore journeys into the world of
context where access and zero trust
networks
[Music]
Slager Bank and Trust like many large
enterprises with a long history of IT
infrastructure turn to a perimeter
security model early on to keep your
corporate resources safe all the good
stuff customer info company data
internal applications etc had to be
protected so they built walls proxies
firewalls and other barriers to keep the
public internet separated from their
private systems that left employees with
two options to get work done sit in the
Slager offices or connect via VPN they
wanted to do better both for security
and usability having recently learned
about context to where they decided to
give it a try but how to start to kick
it off the sleeker IT team did a broad
survey of their existing systems and
applications they identified lumen an
internal marketing analytics app as an
ideal candidate to test out
context-aware access the pic women
because it had a very specific use case
for a specific set of people at the
company and had few outside dependencies
it already ran on the web so required no
platform migration work to ensure
success the sleeker team also got
leadership buy-in early on from IT
security and marketing teams so the top
management knew why they were doing this
and the projected timeline they
explained the benefits of increased
access for employees outside the office
and for partner agencies while also
addressing risks of unauthorized access
or application compromised they began by
getting Moomin running on JCP in their
case using compute engine VMs instead of
their own premise viens once that was up
and running they could activate identity
where a proxy as part of the HTTP load
balancer in front of the cluster they
created simple rules an IEP to allow the
marketing team to view the web app an IT
team to manage access then they started
shifting traffic from their on Prem
instance of women to the GCP instance
watching carefully for errors the Slager
team enjoyed a couple other side
benefits from this shift
they got multi-region availability
reduce latency for workers away from
headquarters and they were able to open
up lumen to specific agency vendors who
had worn for years to use the same
analytics platform to collaborate better
with the internal marketing teams after
the successful first step the Slager
Bank and Trust IT team had gained both
expertise and confidence in using GCP
and eiope together and began to plan
future migrations for other internal
services to get more detail check out my
blog post link below for step-by-step
instructions and subscribe for more
videos on context-aware access when it
comes to protecting your company keep
your data yours
[Music]